[Music]
6 42 it is time now for our weekly
morning cup of joe
with metro sheriff joe lombardo he joins
us live with his
cup of joe hey sheriff how are you
hey good morning out be here good to see
you thanks for joining us so early
what was that we have i think we got a
little delay going here i said happy
thanksgiving
it's all right happy thanksgiving to you
you know speaking of this holiday
weekend is going to be different of
course
is it different from metro's point of
view though and what is metro focusing
on this weekend
yeah it is the holiday season which
a lot of people travel i just heard your
broadcast a little bit earlier about the
increase in
an unexpected increase in numbers of
travelers during this holiday season so
in response to that we usually do a
pretty significant traffic enforcement
during the holiday season
to include aggressive driving speeding
and dui
so we have this program here at metro
it's called joining forces
as whereas all the traffic functions
on the local police departments north
las vegas nhp
henderson they team up and they do dui
enforcement and speed
infraction enforcement it's a pretty
successful program
as far as getting the the bad drivers
off the road and
hoping to curtail the fatal accidents
that occurred during the holiday season
so it's it's a big deal because you know
i was looking through some of the stats
associated with accidents recently and
the national highway safety
administration says that uh 40 billion
dollars
is associated to mitigating traffic
accidents associated with speed so it's
a big deal
so that's what we do
you know after thanksgiving of course we
have black friday and a lot more people
are shopping online this year because of
what's going on
so do you think package thefts will be a
bigger issue this year and what should
people do to prevent that
yeah i do absolutely i think i do well i
think i do i know i do
um i believe it is going to be a big
deal and it has been in previous years
with the proliferation of amazon and
and the ease of receiving items at your
house
but what people need to do is target
harden their own
residence or their own place of business
and you know advise your neighbor if
you're not going to be around or you
expect to receive a package or if you
have a security guard through an hoa
advise them and help maybe they can help
you you know a lot of these
folks follow the ups trucks and the
fedex trucks and
they do what they do they they see the
packets be delivered they follow behind
them and they go grab the package
and subsequently we get involved at that
point
it's important for people to target
hardener their
place of residence in other words have
their video cameras working that's a
definite assist for the police
department do an investigation
and it's important for people to be
aware of their surroundings so
don't make it easy for the crooks it's
unfortunate that people take advantage
of
people's uh um good will and charity
during the holidays
but we know that as a society we have to
deal with that on a regular basis so
it's important for people to be aware
that
and don't post your information on
social media like you're going to be out
of town
or something to that aspect to make it
easier for them
and hopefully we'll all be able to enjoy
ourselves yeah
it's so frustrating to watch those
videos and people even if they see the
ring camera or whatever camera you have
up and they still go and grab the
packages it's so frustrating every year
so that's some good tips all right
sheriff lastly here what other things
will metro focus on to prevent crime
during this holiday season obviously
it's going to be a little different in
terms of shopping and going out to malls
yeah but we still expect a lot of people
to hit the malls you know the brick and
mortar
business is still in business you know
some people aren't comfortable shopping
online
but we have a lot of crime issues in
proximity and the cartilage of the malls
and
shopping areas so with that with that
knowledge
we do very proactive enforcement in
those areas so we
we have the area commands uh concentrate
their efforts during the shopping hours
in the parking lots and with in a lot of
the places hire police officers on an
older time basis to police their
their businesses so we also put plain
clothes folks out in the parking lot
area so
i think it's important for people to
help us help them
and what i mean by that don't have your
packages stacked up inside your car so a
thief walking by could see them and then
eventually steal them if you have the
ability to
hide them in the trunk or the back seat
or take them home
as you go to and fro your your business
of the day
it's important for people to realize
that and be aware of their surroundings
when they're walking to
and from their car so they won't become
a personal victim
of a person attempting to take their
their gifts for the holiday season
yeah don't want that all right sheriff
we are out of time
it is great to see you have a wonderful
thanksgiving hopefully
your wife has some lovely food for you
tomorrow morning thank you for being
with us
uh thank you all right if you have a
question for sheriff joe lombardo
you can send it to us on our website
eightnewsnow.com
and find out if it was answered every
wednesday